ladies and gentlemen could I please have  your attention  I've just been handed an urgent and  horrifying news story we are to start go  ahead drink it in don't be shy there is  plain simple I mean I wake up with more  knife it's excellent it's easy not hard  said it's easy that is poop smells like  Sandra wood and very important  but now the forbidden fruit must be  tasted I think it worked for me we broke  up you just took in the jugular man  definitely feeling a little freaked out  about the fact that I'm gonna have sex  with only one person for the rest of my  life listen can I start over again I  made up a new dance move it's called the  move on with your life  swirl number one again  no you relax  super pencil baking do with God put Ron  Burgundy on this review at salon-quality  hair boy that escalated quickly I mean  that really got out of hand fast